hey they're getting my name is Sam
basher and welcome to new rock stars
Warner Brothers in DC released the first
easier trailer for their first not in
continuity BC story following the origin
of the Joker starring Joaquin Phoenix
director Todd Phillips is bringing this
filmed the big-screen later this year
specifically October 4th and so far
we've got some interesting teasers
including photos and some insane casting
news but now let's dive into the seedy
underbelly of Gotham City once more how
many times does Batman appear in this
trailer more times than I thought I'll
tell you that much Oh spoiler warning of
course for DC Comics movies TV shows etc
let's get going right off the bat I've
got to give credit to the cast crew and
the trailer house for the imagery and
song choice throughout this teaser you
are immediately sucked into this world
and the way our main character Arthur
pluck views it kicking off this trailer
we see a slow zoom in on what looks to
be Gotham Central Hospital where Arthur
is sitting with a social worker but
already we've got some nods to the bat
family literally if you zoom in on her
name tag you'll notice her name
looks to be Deborah Kane now for those
of you who aren't keeping up with the 17
different flavors of bat vigilante Kane
is last name of that woman
Kate Kane we also know that Kate is
Bruce's cousin and the Kanes are a
wealthy family and Gotham even in this
world we take a look at that leaked
Gotham subway map from a few months back
we can see an entire county dedicated to
the Kane family this could be a
different Kane of course but I don't
think it's a coincidence we also know
that this movie is meant to be a
cautionary tale for what society can
turn a man into under the worst of the
worst circumstances hooking up this
trailer with the line doesn't help
having someone to talk to you setting
the tone of how Arthur story will unfold
I'm guessing he should go to a therapist
more often it's not looked at too good
we then see Arthur moving throughout his
corner of Gotham which could possibly be
Burnside or the Bowery both
not-so-pleasant districts in the comics
if you pay attention to how each of
these shots are set up where Arthur's
walking past a pile of garbage and up a
lonely staircase we really get a sense
of how lonely Arthur feels in this city
and in his own skin we also get our
first glance at frances conroy as penny
Fleck Arthur's mother we can gather from
this scene that with her advanced age
she could meet Arthur's constant care
but we do see Arthur's smile around his
mother so possibly this isn't a negative
in his life
or this could possibly be a creepy term
where he's a little bit too possessive
of his mom
I might be jumping to conclusions here
but hey it could happen this is supposed
to be a creepy movie after all we are
then shown Arthur having a bit of a
breakdown in his living room and working
on his stand-up material in this world
Joker begins as a failing comedian much
like The Killing Joke comic but he is
mentally ill and that is made crystal
clear with this shot of his jokes that
he's working on we see a few standard
not so funny jokes but the final line
reads the worst part of having a mental
illness is people expect you to act like
you don't Arthur's world is coming into
focus more and more he's a troubled
individual who is in need of help
possibly that's why we're seeing Deborah
Kane at Gotham central he feels isolated
due to his current mental state and
possibly his living arrangement you'll
notice as well during this scene a
bottle of pills on the table as well as
what looks to be bills that are piling
up with his mother's health in limbo
Arthur might need help more than ever we
then see Arthur signs spinning for a
closeout sale at a music store in his
clown makeup it's pretty obvious in this
instance that stand-up comedy is it
probably working out so great for Arthur
and he's in need of some other work also
you could look at this closure of a
music store of another instance of joy
being drained out of a poor part of
Gotham music is an important escape for
most people and with it being taken away
from these people they could become even
more isolated also you notice in this
shot we get more of a sense of the 80's
aesthetic of this film with the
storefronts and the ever tasteful adult
theater in the background zooming in on
Arthur's costume here and when he is
mugged in the alleyway we start getting
a glimpse or two of his classic Joker
outfit with his green hair flower on his
lapel and the iconic face makeup the
next shot we see is Arthur looking like
he's either trying to rip something
apart or force something back together
after it's been broken from the mugging
that we just saw but during this scene
most importantly we hear Arthur's
narration explain that even though he
feels like he's trying so hard to make
the world a better place or at least
give it some happiness the world keeps
pushing back harder and harder and
possibly he might not be able to keep up
the next shot is one of the few shots
where we see Arthur happy dancing with
his mother but notice the pillow on the
couch
it looks like Arthur's living situation
isn't looking too good with impossibly
sleeping on his mother's couch now
nothing wrong with living at home and
helping out your parents but for his
mental state this might not be the best
thing but also in this scene did you
notice the punk Easter egg on the TV
screen you zoom in
enhance just a little bit not Erik Bosse
shout out you'll notice a few nods here
to the crew members from the Joker no
this is not of a real movie actually Ben
gala Tory the first writer that you see
is the travel coordinator for this film
and will limpert is one of the
production secretaries pretty fine will
shout out in the Joker moving on we see
zazzy beats character Sophie Duman and
Arthur flex eating at a local donut shop
two things worth mentioning here one is
there a sanitation strike or am I not
familiar with trash pile ups in major
cities because wow Gotham is not looking
too good with that enormous garbage heap
also second blink and you'll miss it it
looks like there could be a fun nod to a
certain Gotham TV show on Fox or at
least one of its characters notice the
street sign in the corner of the screen
Jerome is not only a street in the Bronx
no no but also the name of the proto
Joker in Gotham Jerome velasca to be
exact now I'm not a huge fan of Gotham
but if this film has nods to all of the
Joker's who came before
that's all right in my book as for who
Sophie is she is a new character from
what I can tell not in the comics but
her description describes her character
as someone who's just had enough life
has dealt her a few bad hands and she's
a single mother just trying to raise her
kid and Falls for a man who will one day
become the Joker another bad deal I'll
be honest we then see our first shot of
this world's arkham asylum or excuse me
state hospital and boy howdy does it not
look like a healthy place for patients
the most powerful shot in this trailer
being that elevator ride where you see
the patient thrashing about we then get
our first shot of Brian Tyree Henry who
I did not know was going to be in this
movie is that dudes just in everything
right now isn't he now while we don't
know who he will be playing in this
movie as of yet but based on the scene
with him and Arthur behind that middle
divider my guess is that he's an
employee at Arkham and he does not trust
Arthur we then see pocos comedy club
where Arthur's watching a set by himself
and we get that amazing sample of the
Joker laugh
that's perfect and Erie also worth
mentioning it would have been amazing if
they had shot this scene at the Gotham
comedy club in New York I know that they
shot most of this movie in New Jersey
and New York but possibly they swapped
out the sign that reads pogos instead
and it could have been I don't know a
fun in world connection that's just what
I was also worth mentioning Pogo could
be a fun not to a long-running comic
series of the same name it's not DC
comic but it's rather popular back in
the 70s next we see Arthur at what looks
to be a clown school with his back to us
as he's putting on his makeup this looks
to be the location of the previous shot
where Arthur is shaking with his shirt
off and once again we are shown that
Arthur is very alone he is not
interacting with anyone in this scene
he's not even sitting close to another
person also the image of Arthur pulling
his lips up to force a smile while
shedding a tear this is the perfect
example of what's going on inside this
poor man he just needs help possibly
this could be a signal that Arthur is
starting to find the comedy and how the
world is treating him and he just can't
take it anymore
we then see Arthur riding in the subway
and what appears to be the clown outfit
that we saw earlier when he was mugged
but now he's going to be assaulted by a
totally different group of douches and
maybe this is the straw that breaks the
camel's back and forces Arthur to stand
up against the upper class that is
ruining their lives as he sees it and
the rest of the lives of the lower class
in Gotham I'm also guessing during the
scene Arthur finally stands up for
himself
snaps possibly and attacks these boys
possibly killing them my only reason for
thinking this is that the next shot is
of him running under a bridge with his
nose covered in the same blood that we
saw on the subway during that fight and
he looks to be running from what I can
assume to be the police
we then see him and what looks to be his
true Joker form true for the movie
anyway
the narration we hear states that Gotham
has lost its way signaling to us the
viewer that Arthur has now become a
symbol for the disenfranchised in a way
we even see people borrowing his look
and protesting out of an ornate building
in downtown Gotham way up top over there
Wayne Hall are first and certainly not
last not to the Wayne family
why is Arthur getting kicked out of that
Charlie Chaplin exhibit well this could
be a nod to Arthur's love of classic
comedy ie his love of clowns and being a
clown and possibly silent films who
knows also worth pointing out that my
theory of Arthur killing those boys
seems confirmed by the narration by none
other than Thomas Wayne played by Brett
:
also if you notice closely he's dancing
with a rogue
/ right now he's now goon so hot our
friend Arthur by the way very
interesting to dig at a man for wearing
a mask in doling out justice mr. Wayne
Batman's dad we didn't see what looks
like the previously released footage of
the Joker exiting a subway car while his
followers attacked someone in a suit
while we now can confirm that who they
are attacking our cops if you notice
right here one of these men chasing
Arthur is wearing a badge following this
we see Arthur stalking the perimeter of
an estate enforcing a young boy to smile
that isn't just any boy my dudes that
boy is none other than Bruce Wayne
confirmed by IMDB wowie-zowie the Joker
is way older than Batman in this world
please don't put your dirty adult hands
in that boy's mouth we didn't see arthur
flashing between multiple emotional
states happily dancing in his underwear
to him smashing his head into a mirror
showing that he is going to now fully
embrace the madness around him this
leads us to see him in his full Joker
suit and makeup going on to Murray
Franklin's talk-show that character
played by Robert De Niro and it's worth
mentioning the De Niro's character in
this movie is a slight nod to his
character Rupert in Martin Scorsese's
king of comedy where he also played a
talk-show host also a little criticism
to Murray because this might not be the
best person to bring onto your show
probably shouldn't give him a platform
because especially he's inspiring people
to you know incite violence and attack
cops
we then see Arthur running to escape
what looks to be my guess Arkham Asylum
possibly following his violent actions
earlier but this seam leads us to Joker
being struck by a car but finally during
these last few shots of this trailer we
were able to see the full metamorphosis
from Arthur to Joker with him dyeing his
hair at the classic Joker green and
revisiting the staircase and hallway
that we saw earlier in the movie where
he was portrayed as a loner but now we
see the sun shining and he's finally
looking empowered a little bit more sure
of himself good for him unless you know
he's killing people we're left with one
final shot of him smiling as the in
elevator door is closing and I am
interested but what did you guys think
over all of this trailer could the death
of his mother and the violent assaults
from total strangers be the reason he
becomes the voice of the downtrodden in
Gotham will we see more DC nods
throughout the movie other Batman
villains possibly why do you think they
name the Joker Affleck Arthur Fleck you
guys caught that before I did but so
kudos to you let me know down below but
also don't forget to subscribe and share
this video and then you can follow me on
Twitter if you want to add Sam bash sure
and make sure you check out our podcast
new
Stars debrief anywhere you get your
podcast they'll keep you busy for a
little bit until our next breakdown
I'll see you then bye
[Music]